I used one Graham packet of safe guard, Fenn Bendazole daily for my cancer protocol.
When I tried taking two packets daily, I was having chronic diarrhea, so I went back to one packet
a day and started the sun fiber supplement. So sun fiber is a modified Guarangum that is a great
sort of the best forms of fiber out there. I finally became regular for the first, for the last month.
So I introduced a second packet of Fenn Bendazole daily and after a couple days the diarrhea started
again, should I avoid doing it twice a day all together? Yes, yes I would. So Fenn Bendazole for
those who don't know is a dewormer. And the dosage that this person is taking is a dog dosage
for a 10 pound dog. So what does that affect as I have on a human? It's a very low dose
dewormer. And it shouldn't have very much affected as far as antiparasitic and deworm, but some
people can have sensitivity to it. Some people just have a sensitive gut note. Typically,
when a person asks me if this person was a patient, they're asking me that question.
I would be concerned about the health of their gut. So I would say, really, we should run a
Cyrex array, too, because we really need to see if there's, you know, a paracelular permeability,
transcellular permeability, or if you have antibodies to lipopolysaccharides because you shouldn't react
to two packets of this. Now, I know who asked this question. Obviously, if this person is very small,
or this person has other health issues, sounds like they're taking it for cancer. So, but I would say,
you know, anytime you take anything supplementally and you have a reaction to it, you should stop
taking it. So, you know, just because maybe your sister can take it, you might have a sensitivity
to it. You might need to deal with other things in your gut or something like that. Maybe you have,
it's not a sensitivity, but you have other gut permeability issues and it's just too much irritation.
Maybe there's some of the things you need to do. There's just a lot of babies there. So even good
supplements like, okay, curcument, curcument is the active form of tumouric. Well, that's great,
because it's an anti-inflammatory, it's a cancer killer, it's a great supplement, but it is a food
and you can develop antibodies against curcument. I've done, you know, different antibody tests on
people and they have antibodies for tumouric. Well, they can't take curcument. So, it's, you know,
there's, you know, everybody's a different human being. So, that's where when you look at advice that's
on the internet or even given by good doctors that are saying that everybody should do this or
everybody should do that. Maybe they just meet it in general, but I will say that everybody is different.
So, you may be different than your twin sister and you can't do the same thing. So, getting some proper
testing done is the right thing to do. And in general, if you have a reaction to something, just stop it
for a period of time and do some investigation. Maybe it wasn't that supplement at all. Maybe it was
something else that you ate that day that you had the reaction. Obviously, this question, it's quite
obvious that it is the Femid, it's all this person tested it, they got their cut back in order,
whether they tested it and took it again and it happened again. So, it's pretty easy to see that,
but some things aren't as easy to see and things can get blamed. One of the things I make of the
steak being a functional doctor and I don't prescribe one of the things, I'll just be honest, that I
make a mistake off and it's forgetting that a lot of members of ours are also taking concurrently,
taking prescription medication. And they may say, well, I had this reaction the other day to this thing,
you know, I got this and this and this reaction of like, oh, goodness, let's change, let's change your
supplement protocol, let's do this, let's do that. Let's check this and I forget, good to say,
you're on this, this, this, this drug, let's look up side effects. Oh, three of the four drugs you have
have that as a side effect. Maybe it's that, you know, you just got to investigate all those things
and be wise, sometimes just involves you putting on your Sherlock Holmes hat and you just kind of
figure these things out. But certainly finding a local doctor that could do testing can be a wise
thing to do. If you want to work with us again, you're to schedule a case review with us.
And get at our courses, I mean, go to cutterscletic.com. I think this scrolling at the bottom of the
screen is talking about our courses are $50 for our autoimmune course. And from there, you can run
labs and you can set schedule, you can schedule visits with us on such, it's really a good buy if you
really want to take responsibility for your health.